my thoughts and those of everyone in the
met police
are with sarah's loved ones it's not
possible
for any of us to begin to imagine what
they have been going through
i was able to speak to them earlier
today
and say again how very sorry
i am for their loss
and for their pain and their suffering
all of us in the met are sickened
angered and devastated by this man's
crimes
they are dreadful
and everyone in policing feels betrayed
sarah was a fantastic talented young
woman
with her whole life ahead of her
and that has been snatched away
she was hugely loved and she will be
sorely missed by so very many people
ever since sarah went missing the
sole priority of
my investigation team the search team
and hundreds of others
in the met and beyond
was to find sarah and to bring
the person who had committed
these terrible crimes to justice
as swiftly as we possibly could
in this we are hugely indebted
to sarah's family and to her friends
and to many members of the public who
helped the investigation in every single
way they could
not least by making appeals
and giving us information
no words can adequately express
the profound sadness and anger
and regret
that everyone in the met in my police
service
feels about what happened to sarah
today as every day
our thoughts are with sarah with her
family
with her loved ones and they always
will be